we've been talking so far about the
challenges that men face in the modern
world problems of masculinity you've
spent a good bit of time with Tate
what were your thoughts after having
spent time with him how do you think
he's contributing to the conversation of
masculinity why is he failing and
falling short
I think the problem was all the short
form content that was
getting put out there obviously it was
just like the most extreme out of
context Clips mostly from some of his
old videos
so when he when he started off he's been
doing content for a long time his older
videos are just wild like he's just
saying some mad [__] but he can do
because nobody is even watching right so
there's when not many people are
watching your videos you can get away
with saying a lot more as he became
drastically popular obviously people
going back to the old videos and were
like what the hell they were using that
content and it was just going crazy
I when I first came across him he
actually DM me this was in 2021 and
um
I went on his Instagram and I went to a
few pictures and I just thought
who is this guy like it seemed like he
was
um
trying to show off a little bit too much
and I thought it was all just a front
you know how a lot of people out here
just
fake they're just trying to drink cars
trying to show hey I've got money that's
what I thought when I saw him I was like
this guy's just chatting [__] but then I
did a little bit of research and I
listened to some of the podcasts I think
the first one you went on the other to
do was fresh and fit
and then that was the first time I'd
actually listened to someone I was like
whoa like this guy this guy is speaking
in a way that I've never heard anyone
speak before and he's saying things
which I haven't really heard anyone say
before so I was intrigued and I want to
listen to more and I was like actually
you know what I want to meet this guy so
we came to Dubai we linked up we did the
videos
especially to see I think I mean he's
always he's always doing business
wherever he goes
but I guess maybe that was part of the
plan at that point he just wanted to
because he saw he must have seen me
probably thought oh yeah Mike seems like
a cool guy but he saw the audience and
then he probably thinks you know what
like he was obviously on a mission to
grow get more followers so we can push
whatever he needs to push so he probably
would have seen me okay yeah I'll do a
video on Mike and then I can help me out
with my branding and exposure obviously
that works very well but um
yeah I met him in real life and he's
he's actually
an even better guy I know a lot of
people don't like him but he in real
life he's like a nice guy
polite exactly funny
and um I think that's a side which a lot
of people don't see because they he
definitely just put on some kind of a
character especially in the videos which
He makes himself
and he says things and I'm just like
like why do you say that
it's like 70 of the stuff he says he's
like yeah like I strongly agree with
that and then he will go and say
something absolutely ridiculous and it's
just like why did you need to say that
because that's the 30 that people are
going to focus on yeah yeah I think
again this didn't quite come up
yesterday it came up with uh Jordan
Peterson as the example but I said
something to the effect of
um if you're not happy with the role
models that are currently being held up
for men
offer up other ones and I asked the guy
that was across from me the debater who
do you think is a good role model for
men
and he struggled a little bit uh he
struggled a lot actually it's hard to
find someone who's the full package I
think correct but I was I was able to
say well look like it's not perfect but
I would say that the kind of man that
Peterson would tell you to be your
Andrew huberman's of the world your Tim
ferrisses of the world your Joe Rogan's
of the world your Joker will links like
these are people that seem to have codes
of honor and ethics they do hard things
they're courageous and brave like you
know they don't get into drama they
don't get into drama I should have just
said Mike Thurston but
it's weird that more people don't want
it more men don't want to be like those
guys
well I don't know maybe they do maybe
they do it's just that they're not
selling that kind of sexy out their
lifestyle because it doesn't necessarily
resonate like it's hard it's it's hard
difficult nuanced suffering things
I mean homozy man I was spent I spent uh
Saturday with him last week in in Vegas
podcasted trained
and I went to the power slap launch
thing with him and the guys an
unbelievably slick operator he's one of
the most impressive yeah people that
have really been getting into his
content he's a terrifyingly competent
human right
but I don't even know if he owns a car I
just eons eat they've maybe have like a
car but it's like A tes like a nice
Tesla right the guy sold his business
for 100 Mil he's now doing acquisition
deals for [__] lots and lots of money
so the and this kind of maybe explains a
little bit of of the tape phenomenon
which was that his delivery was so
compelling because say what you want
about what he says the way that he says
it is incredibly interesting and it's
very very compelling very precise
speaker good with his words you know to
go head-to-head with Piers Morgan Piers
Morgan is as hard-nosed as you're going
to get very very good in a cantankerous
debate and he Charmed Piers Morgan twice
and beat him at chess right
he's a very competent guy but he gets
like I'll be honest when I this was last
summer I was listening to a lot of his
podcasts and he was getting me fired up
to work
the stuff he says about women I just I
usually will just ignore but when he
talks about just
doing the job regardless of how you feel
just get the job done
wake up early go to the gym
and
the fact that there's just so many other
people out there that are your potential
competitors if you don't get out there
and put the work in then they're gonna
overtake you but remember that that is
David Goggins and Joker willink's
message to a t with different delivery
and with a different package that's
being folded into what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full unedited episode and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]
thank you